so we're looking at wow a really thick
haze over the city again this morning
and
people always ask you know what is the
haze i'll show you come in here in the
air quality report in just a moment but
there is a city out there the skyline is
barely visible as we look across this
morning and it's really always worse in
the morning because that's when the
pollutants are really really at their
worst and we've got the early morning
commute so you've got more cars out
there putting their exhaust fumes out 75
degrees 25 humidity and the dew points
in the 30s so the air is dried and dried
out a lot more and the temperatures have
cooled it just feels it feels great
outside sunrise 603 and 724 is the
sunset so we've got 70s in the valley
we've got cooler 60s outside the valley
indian springs prom sandy valley feels
fantastic 70s boulder city low 70s
mesquite upper 70s in laughlin 71 in
kingman look at the 40s up in cedar city
it's almost freezing up in ely 52 in
caliani and mid 50s in tonopah right now
only 80s only 80s in death valley
instead of triple digits so smoke
advisory has been extended through
sunday now the air quality overall
moderate once we get through the morning
hours it should start being a little bit
better midday through the afternoon but
really the air quality it's a haze is a
mix of dust smoke elevated ozone the
pollutants in the air from exhaust fumes
all of that mixed together and very
unhealthy for sensitive groups a lot of
smoke again concentrated in california
up into northern nevada and as we get
southerly winds tomorrow and into early
sunday that's going to help push we hope
push more of the smoke up north not good
for our neighbors up north but hopefully
it'll thin out a little bit for us in
southern nevada there's the low pressure
system moving into the northern rockies
with showers they need as much rain as
they can get up north where the fires
are as well and we've got tropical storm
henri off the west off the east coast
excuse me is expected to strengthen to a
hurricane but not make landfall so we'll
stay hazy but we will get those winds
increasing for everywhere for the valley
the mountains and especially the lake
tomorrow 73 on the mountain today
beautiful temperatures up there near 100
at the lake and please wear the life
jackets especially tomorrow when those
winds get rougher upper 90s for the
valley hazy sunshine today staying below
normal today and tomorrow those winds 25
miles an hour could even be a little bit
stronger triple digits come back as soon
as sunday and i mean hot next week near
110 by friday